man all
right this is what happens when you do
it live let's do it
again ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for the second
time this
morning to your favorite
podcast
[Music]
w with
Griffin
g
w
g anyways guys welcome
back to riffin with
Griffin all right so
today we'll do uh NFL talk um I love the
first six weeks of the
season on Instagram I've been going in
on this Will and Jada stuff so we'll
talk about that plus some important news
from
around the world give you some thoughts
people probably been wondering what I
think so let's talk about it now welcome
back
[Music]
to I don't know how that mic
sounds anyways y'all welcome back to
riffin with Griffin you know what's
crazy is they got you know you you you
whatever software you use they they have
these updates for the softare that comes
out and then it messes up whatever you
normally doing and that's what happened
today but anyways welcome back to riffin
with Griffin um make sure you
subscribe um you know hit what is what
is going on there make sure you
subscribe share all that great stuff you
know if you're on uh twitch you know I
I'm on Twitch all the time so check me
out there and as somebody said last week
I don't know a comment I don't know why
Griffin is talking about his patreon
I don't know either really but you know
it's
just I'm I'm working on it I promise you
it's just good to if you just want to
support you know so I appreciate that
all the things that you guys do there
you know for for riffin with Griffin and
thanks for being here y'all as always
um all right let's see what we got here
so I'm just all flustered because of
what happened this morning but you know
we are here and again welcome back to
riffin with
Griffin
so today I had to start early today
because I got a big doctor's appointment
you know we're at 25 weeks uh things are
going well pretty good Rachel's healthy
and happy and moving around and you know
she's moving and grooving and doing
stuff and you know we're setting up the
nursery
and buying all kinds of nonsense I mean
it's really exciting oh man as I said
last week you know I felt the baby kick
and it was just like I burst into tears
and now it's just just you know you're
thinking about your life you're thinking
about like you know when you're about to
have a baby you're like damn this my
life's about to change forever right you
know
like just the things that you do and the
things that you think about and it's
just really like you know I hope I'm
prepared for it you know a lot of my
friends lot of people tell me got a lot
of comments you're like oh you going to
be a great dad you know I feel the
pressure of that uh it's like I want to
be I don't have a good example of it for
myself um but it's you know it's
exciting so that that's uh why I'm up
early today to do doing this even though
my thing got messed up so you know I'm
going to spend the day with Rachel we're
going to the doctor we're going to go to
like some furniture baby place you know
so it's like you know that all that kind
of stuff is going that's like your life
becomes just all
babies even on my um Instagram algorithm
it's just everything is like baby stuff
you know and then I just send that over
to like a little folder that Rachel and
I share
so that's pretty exciting that's all
that's going on there
excuse me with the baby
update um then let's see what's going on
um so I was out on the road with Matt
rif I was in Ohio with Matt from it was
like a five days 10 shows I I can't
believe it it was like a
Wednesday and the show a Wednesday night
by the way Wednesday night and the show
is completely sold out two shows on
Wednesday night in his huge theater in
his hometown area of Columbus so that
was crazy you know uh oh please tell me
that this is not messing
up um
anyways
um uh I don't know what's happening here
I hope the I hope the stream is still
going I got it looks like it paused on
my thing so sorry if it's uh you know
this is a weird thing to say during
right in the middle of a podcast but let
let me just actually refresh this to
make sure I'm getting
this it's just one of these moures man I
don't even know you know what I
mean
so anyways I think we're still going
good yeah it looks like we're still
going good did your did your live shut
off I think you have to just refresh
something's going on with YouTube so I
got a notification that YouTube is
changing their they looks like they said
they're changing how they go live
they're doing some kind of thing and so
it's like I don't know but anyways I'm
in um if it's good it's good if it's not
it's not it is what it is so I went to
again so we're like you know Wednesday
night two shows Thursday night two shows
Friday night two shows Saturday night
two shows Sunday night two shows a you
know awesome time out there crazy people
in the crowd so much crazy stuff is
happening you know people are trying to
record and people are yelling and we
have to kick people out because they're
just disturbing the show but at the same
time it's just a great show most of the
people were great so if anybody that's
watching my podcast now you saw me out
in Ohio with Matt R thanks for being
here now and it was uh you know I had a
great time um oh yeah that's that is
what it was you know an ad popped up oh
so that messes up my thing so what it is
is like I
think whatever we I'm not going to do
that again so anyways um all right so
let's just get right into comments this
week get into the comments and I also
have a c oh I didn't put the Q&A up oh
because that was the last stream so I
don't know what happened oh no I did
wait no did I let's see uh no I did not
start
Q&A what you
got all right there we go just do that
little Q&A real quick um I actually have
a question from someone it's not an
official uh real world device from a
grown ass man but you know if somebody
sends me a question that I think is you
know I should answer it then I'm just
going to you know I'm I'm going to
answer it so and he did somebody sent me
a good question so I'll get into that
one last on on uh on this segment of the
the
show um jade somebody said shout out to
Eric's crappy
site yeah I really got to work on my
website and I know I talk about this all
the time but people send me messages
like oh I want to help you but it's like
it's never
like it's hard to explain but it's I do
want to make a new site but it has to be
something that I can manage myself I'm
not you know what I mean it's like it's
very difficult so this one that I have I
know how to do it I just change the
dates and whatever you know what I mean
like who's really going to websites
these days like if for a comic you just
go to the website just to get like where
where are you going to perform can I buy
tickets I don't know if you're going to
websites now to be like oh let me see
what's going on in the news and
information so I don't know if people
are using websites the way they used to
you know cuz if you can follow follow me
you go to your Instagram a person's
Twitter a person's Tik Tok you go into
like that stuff and I don't know if
you're necessarily going to their
website but I don't know man so you know
it is it's the
[Laughter]
worst
uh all right let's see here I got
something in Russian so that I don't
know what this is so I'm going to remove
it because you know when somebody writes
and you don't know what they're
saying that's see K KY Aaron 39 said get
your hairy Knuckles out of my face and
he laughs that was from the Bobby and
Steve episode people are still looking
at that episode it's
crazy um and then somebody said this is
like somebody I'm not even GNA read that
one because I don't
care
[Music]
um let's see Mark Vino ven ven C 8386
said hey you can break rules but don't
break flutes by putting too much
pressure on
it I don't know what that one's
about uh let's see here I saw one good
one um oh here we go to Toco
l42 Yellow 5 is in a lot of products and
has been linked to hyperactive activity
disorders that they want to save
everybody uh they got a ADHD and need
medicines um yeah so this guy is talking
about you
know how last week I was talking about
how they they're banning Skittles but
they're actually Banning like a couple
of like ingredients that are in the
Skittles and I think they're going to
ban these ingredients because they're in
like 12,000 of our ingredients in our
products you know if to me it's like if
if in another country if in numerous
other countries they're banning a
product for health reasons who are we to
be like oh you're Banning it there oh
yeah but we're cool over here I have a
huge problem with
that just as a country it it does
everything have to be about money and
quick quick you know like man it's so
scary to think that when you look at
what happened with oxycotton you know
that they did that strictly for money so
many lives were destroyed and ruined for
because of that choice to think that
they wouldn't do that that's not that
that's the only isolated incident of
that happening don't fool yourself you
know don't fool yourself so this is to
me it's like you know we have to really
as a nation think about this man you
know what I mean
like we have to we have to like be more
aware of what we're putting in our
bodies so so I I say to you like look
out for yourself really you know because
don't trust that don't trust that the
government actually is is going to be
the ones that are going to be like hey
don't worry we we're looking out for
public health and we're going to make
sure that the right stuff gets in your
body it doesn't seem like they're
they've been doing that ever
so scary part about that right
um Mark hatch
6809 that recap was effing
hilarious yeah I like
recapping Fast and the Furious movies
because they are so ridiculous so look
back next week maybe I'll just get that
part and put that on Instagram or
something like that but uh it was
crazy um let's
see all right you know what that's good
enough that's good enough of these
comments for this week guys that's good
enough let me check the Q&A see if
anybody has any questions here somebody
put something in the
Q&A are you playing the new Call of Duty
says David S yes I am I already got it
from my Xbox and Playstation love Call
of Duty it's my favorite game of all
time uh somebody said what's for
breakfast I don't know it's really up to
Rachel we got to see what she's going to
do going to play Spider-Man 2 somebody
else said um I do like this that first
Spider-Man was great I just don't like
games that end now like you know what I
mean like when they have an ending I
just I like these games that just can go
on and on and on it's really fun stuff
but I might play it because it usually
last a really long time to play and then
somebody said are you coming back to San
Antonio no I am not coming back to San
Antonio but I will say this thank you
for bringing that up huh thank you for
bringing that up so speaking of going to
my terrible
website let's see what shows I have
coming up guys let's see what shows I
have coming up and I have a bunch of
shows coming up so this weekend Florida
area Fort Lauderdale area in between
Miami I think daa improv in Florida just
two nights Saturday Friday and Saturday
at The Improv you can go to my website
click that link go to tickets or you can
go to Danel improv you know to get those
tickets two shows and my buddy Vincent
oan is going to be with me he's really
funny so come check it out if you're in
the Florida area come check it out I'm
going to be at the comedy zone in
Greenville October 27th and 28th just
two nights come check me out there
Greenville uh Orlando Improv one night
November 2nd no Orlando Improv so come
on let's let's let's take care of that
I want to sell that sucker out come on
Orlando area let's do that and S
Splitters in Tampa Florida that same
weekend now so it's Thursday in in uh in
Orlando and then Tampa the third and
fourth at Sid Splitters so come check me
out okay appreciate that
y'all all right let's go here let's see
what we got here um all right guys so
first up let's let's just go into the
NFL real quick I'm going to tell you my
top five teams and my thoughts about
what's been going on in the NFL so far I
think the season's great if you're not
into the NFL this is a good time you I'm
not going to go into to depth but I'm
just saying I really enjoyed the first
six weeks of the NFL some of the teams
that we thought were going to be good
didn't weren't good but like the Jets
for instance you know the Jets lost
Aaron roders that was the big story and
then they got this guy Zack Wilson he's
like he was a second pick in the draft
but he's not living up to expectations
but I'll say this I think that if you
have Super Bowl
aspirations all facets of the game have
to be pretty good and consistent not
just the quarterback so you got
quarterback play you have offense
defense special teams and then you have
the two the offensive line and the
defensive line all aspects of the of
those things have to be pretty good for
you to be considered a Super Bowl
Contender now if one of those aren't
good you would hope that the others are
good enough to to like help with that
deficiency of your team so it's good for
me it's good to see that the Jets are
now three and three um and you know
they're beating good teams they should
be able to if they if Aaron Rogers can't
be the the only thing that makes them
great no it's that defense the Special
Teams it it's all facets of the game and
then they can help with Zack Wilson's
deficiencies you know what I'm saying so
it doesn't seem like um it doesn't seem
like
that's that's it seems like that's
starting to happen so then then then you
have hope that that next next um what do
you call it when Aaron Rogers comes back
if he does next year or even at the end
of this year you're like hey we have a
good team and then there's hope for the
next season because they they got all
the facets of the game together so I
like that story about the Jets I feel
they're good but let me give you
my top five teams in the NFL so far the
the way I see it I think the 49ers are
still the best team even though they
lost they lost the game in the rain they
lost their two of their best offensive
players and they still had a chance to
win the guy just missed a field goal it
happens people rarely go undefeated but
I think that from top to bottom the
49ers have the best team in the NFL you
know and their weakest position is
actually quarterback but he's
serviceable he doesn't make a lot of
mistakes he had his worst he had his
first lost as a quarterback and his
worst game ever this past game but you
know I think he'll bounce back to prove
himself to be a great team I think the
next best team in the NFL is the the
Chiefs they're five- one they're they're
the defending champs and the teams that
they've played are just topnotch they've
won games they don't look the same but
they're winning games they're finding
ways to win games so right now and it's
you know this could change but right now
I go 49ers Chiefs next up I think it's
the Miami Dolphins that offense is
prolific they're five- one two is
playing good Tyreek Hill is looking like
he's going to break the receiving record
F you know he look he's going to get
2,000 yards as a receiver I think the
Dolphins are they're so fun to watch
that defense is a little like eh but
we'll see but right now they're five and
one I really like them a lot next up I
got
the
Lions I know who would have thought
right the Lions I think the Lions
they're ready it might not be this year
it might be next year but they look good
jff G is f he's found himself the guy
was in the Super Bowl with uh the Rams
right so he knows how to
win and now it looks like he really has
a a coach and a team that believes in
him and all the draft picks that they
got and and they're good F all the Rams
draft picks that they got are now
kicking in and they are looking good man
five- one next up and it's real close
between these two teams Detroit and the
next one I would say would be the Eagles
who are also five and one but they have
been looking a little
shaky um you know U Jaylen Herz had his
worst outing three interceptions just
that's not really like him I think
they're going to bounce back and
ultimately I feel like they're probably
going to be with the 49ers one and two
and it's going to be 1 a 1B right but
for now I feel like they are the fourth
or did I say all five yeah I did I did
say all five um teams did I miss a team
I think I did miss a team no I didn't
yeah so I
got yeah so it's
49ers
Chiefs
dolphins
Detroit and the
Eagles and we'll see what happens by the
end of the season I mean the the
schedules are really about to get tight
so you got to look up and there's some
other honorable mentioned teams that are
going on that are playing really well
right now like the Ravens have had a
couple of suspect losses but they were
really close and they made some mistakes
but they look good the Jags look good
they're 4- two so look out for the Jags
right now the bills are 4 and two
obviously the bills are going to be
right there in it so they look good so
that you you know what I mean and then
in the other conference you know you got
the Cowboys they won a big game and you
know Cowboys fans want them that was a
big game they needed to win that game
they're 4- two so they're right there um
Seahawks they're right there too the
Seahawks are looking good they're on a
buy but they they had a buy so they're
only three and two but they're looking
good and that's pretty much it I think
uh you know the long shot is the
Buccaneers but that conference is so
terrible they will make the playoffs
again like like every conf every
division has to send a team to the
playoffs if they win the division so I
feel like the Bucks are going to win
that Division and they they're just
looking you know but that's just like
ridiculous and a surprise team is like
the tit the Texans who are three and
three and that rookie is looking
fantastic it's not it's not Bri which I
keep confusing them is it Bryce Young
and the other one is which one is the
Houston Texans uh quarterback but
whatever that dude is good so look look
out for them I don't think they're going
to make the playoffs but they're looking
good man they are looking
good okay so enough NFL talk um oh you
know what I forgot to do my question so
here's a quick here's a quick real world
advice from a grown ass man somebody
sent me this question on Instagram you
know he even says real world advice
question my girlfriend was snooping on
my computer and reading convos I've had
with my friends she found out I bought
an engagement ring so now the surprise
is ruined no matter when I propose she
knows it's coming how mad should I be
because I'm pretty freaking mad he said
all
right I understand why you're mad I
mean you know I I I often I feel like
like she knows you're going to propose
anyway I feel like have you been talking
about it you know it's like have you
been talking about rings izes has she
been hinting to you like when are we
going to get married cuz that's what a
lot of women do anyway that's what
Rachel did to me you know it's just
that's what women do they they know they
want to get married they know you're
about to do it they they know things are
happening and you want to actually in my
opinion you want to
involve your partner in the ring process
trust
me you know unless you're like giving
her your grandmother's ring you know
those kind of things and I don't really
think women like that honestly but they
want to be involved you know they do
like Rachel was like I said what ring do
you want and she was like and it was
like for months she didn't know what
kind of like diamond you know so I said
go to the store you like pick out three
rings you like and I'll get one of them
you know and that's what she did so I'm
saying a lot of couples they get
involved this way right so I was it a
complete and utter surprise that you're
asking her I don't know so I I know what
to assume in this cuz he didn't give me
a lot of information in this question
but I will say this you love her you
want to marry her yeah you wanted it to
be a surprise and you could still have
fun with it you don't have to be upset
about it I think the thing that you're
really upset about is that she's
violating your privacy and going through
your messages that's a whole other issue
that you want to discuss with her you
know you want to come to go to her and
be like hey see you ruined this but you
can still have fun with it you don't
have to be furious about it remember the
surprise isn't for you it's for her okay
so I understand that she took away this
moment for you to be like maybe she's
been pressuring the guy like and then
he's kind of been putting it off but
that's part of the surprise so when he
actually reveals it she'll be like oh my
God I can't you know what I mean but
either way remember it is a good thing
that you're trying to do you could deal
with her later about the the violation
of privacy and then you could tell her
in the like Hey listen you might find
out something that you don't want to
find out uh you know the you know you
look how you ruin the surprise by doing
that I mean it's like a trust issue that
that's a whole other issue you want to
deal with her about you know is it
something that she does all the time but
look check this out too if you're not
doing anything bad who cares you know
here's my phone check take a look look
at my messages if it doesn't matter but
this thing might happen you get what I'm
saying but I don't think it's something
that you should be so upset about don't
ruin the specialness of you being in
love with this woman and wanting to
marry her don't let that get tarnished
by this one action okay because again I
don't know all the details because it
could be that she knew you were trying
to do something that she's just trying
to find out I remember even with me
like I had the Tiffany's
receipt in my wallet and I keep it on
the counter and like later Rachel tells
me she was like I looked I saw I was I
don't know why she was looking through
my wallet but she just was and she found
a receipt and she was like oh my God and
she didn't tell me to later right this
just what they do man this is what they
do but I still was able to surprise her
cuz I said you know what I did I'll tell
you you have the ring now she knows
you're going to do it now hide it and
wait and then you just like now you do
kind of things like hey babe I have
something to tell you and then like you
know you get on your knees and you tie
your shoe you know what I mean you're
like what what did you think I and now
you make it a thing make it a game you
know but remember the love
you know what I mean you remember the
love you know uh and like I
say um and no I'm not and then there's
an idiot in chat I'm not glossing over
the snooping I'm not what I'm saying is
don't let that ruin your relationship uh
you're an idiot if you think your
woman's not snooping okay I'm sorry it's
just it's you know your phone's right
there it just happens man don't do
anything wrong then snooping won't be a
problem you know what I mean a lot of
people that they have their passwords or
their partner stuff I'm saying this is
more important than fighting over that
he said he's really mad because he he's
mad in my opinion I feel like the guy's
mad because the surprise was ruined but
the snooping is like you know that's
something you could deal with so put
that aside for now and compart
compartmentalize and
remember that it's about
the uh the thing you're trying to do
this special thing because you gonna
have to deal with her on
that like you know when a guy start
talking about you know girls going
through their phone the ones that are
worried about it the most are ones that
got something to
hide the you know it's like you got if
if you don't worry about anything then
don't worry about it you know if you you
trust whatever it is like that again
it's nuanced because
if she already knew that something was
happening and she just couldn't help
herself it's like little kids searching
for Christmas gifts man you know what I
mean that could be part of it if she's
continuously always snooping it doesn't
trust him if it's trust issues then
y'all need to have a bigger discussion
about that but I'm making it light I
don't I don't think because of the
nature of how he wrote this message I
don't think that it's us a big issue you
know I don't think it's a big issue
um you know what I mean so I think that
that's like you know you know this all
male chat is like you know don't be
stupid on my phone you know they all
worried about that but again it's Case
by case you know what I mean it's all
about intentions you know some people
have relationships where it doesn't even
matter their phones are right there and
you can be like hey babe can you check
my phone and you know look up this
address for me or whatever you know what
I mean there's a lot of things like that
it's like you know it's like hey babe
order GrubHub here's my phone you just
do it you know she happens to go look
it's like you know just make sure you're
not
doing anything bad you know what I mean
but again that that trust issue that
people might have I get it that is an
issue I'm not trying to like say that
that's not important it is but I think
what's more important in this situation
is that he did he feels ready to marry
her so he knows however she is it's not
like he wrote to me m girl I have trust
issues with M girl and I'm all she's
always doing this I think this is an
isolated incident and and it it blew up
in her face you know so don't make it
more than it is gentlemen but you know
you never know so anyways that's a
little little peak of real world advice
uh from a grown ass man
okay what do I want to get into next
let's go into this uh let's let's go
into like what I have been obsessed
about for the last
freaking week man this why does do this
man it
doesn't go
live I don't understand this
anyways I'll just do this and then
this and now it'll go live now here we
go let's do
it let's do it so
Will Smith and J pinket
Smith what is happening so apparently
she she's writing a book okay she's
writing a book let me put this over here
so I can see the chat she's writing a
book and a sort of memoir you know a
tell all you know in in the same way
that Britney Spears is I didn't know she
was writing this tell all book and this
is what happens they start revealing
stuff and we're like like Britney Spears
revealed that her and Justin Timberlake
had an abortion I don't know if that's
something that we should know about
right like should we know that it's like
and then you look back and you go oh man
they were young their careers and they
made this Choice whe whether or however
you feel about that I don't think that's
our business I really have an issue with
that so now Catu she's writing this
Memoir they already
have Will and Jada is already a TMI
relationship now
this all this stuff that's coming out so
the first thing that one of the first
things she revealed is that they've been
separated since
2016 if you even go back in
2013 the way she was talking about like
you know that they have an open
relationship she didn't even but she
didn't say it like that she just implied
it she knew what she was doing and then
this red table talk all this information
they're revealing about their
relationship ship it's like what so then
you already looking at them like what
the hell is going on so now you cut to
she's claiming that they've been
separated living apart for seven
years six seven years that made me go
well let's go back to Oscar Knight what
the hell
happened if you're telling me now that
y'all are not even really together why
are you representing to the world like
you're running for office like you're
this like you know Beacon of oh we this
is a relationship it's like no what this
this is this is terrible and your
business should be kept
private you know you know all the stuff
she's coming out with you know oh my my
son introduced me to psychedelics which
saved me what do we need to know
that I mean I guess look it's all for
the money right because
I might go bu this Memoir to find out
about how crazy this family is you know
what I
mean but so I go back to Oscar Knight
and I think they're sitting there
they're not even together this is a sham
they're like hey can you come with me to
this so people think we're happily
married is that why it was why didn't he
just bring a date you know but again
this is the squeaky King clean image
that Will Smith wants to put out about
himself and then whatever pressures he
felt that he has to do that suck
I mean it's it's a shame it's like this
really you know this like Dynamic actor
he's got that it Factor thing like Tom
Cruz where you're just kind of like oh
man I love everything he's in and you
know his star already started to fade uh
when his movies weren't doing as well
you know when he came out with that
after Earth or whatever the stupid movie
that was with his kid when those movies
started to like not be number one at the
box office when his action movie started
to fade when Bad Boys was you know I
don't know why they're continuing that
it's not doing what it did before he
don't have the same star power but this
guy is smart as hell he goes okay I'mma
switch over to Instagram and then he
comes over to Instagram and he becomes
this huge Instagram presence and you
know you know what I mean so he's like
going with the times he knows how to
adapt he's like all right you don't like
me in movies anymore I'mma do this I'mma
Be a celebrity this way I'mma produce
things I'm G make different types of
movies now like I'm like you know
emancipation and like uh you know he's
going to make like Oscar type movies now
he's like he's he's he's like all right
I'm not going to be a box off off smash
now I'm going to be an art guy right so
the guy's Smart in that way I think this
one was not a smart move to fake your
marriage I just don't I I just don't
think it was necessary anymore I don't
think we care anymore of like even if
like the president the president let be
a bachelor now who cares I don't I don't
know if that's like this kind of like
white picket fence mother and father in
the you know if it's not working rather
I think we rather see the the truth of
what's going on in their marriage I
don't think anyone would have cared if
if seven years AG they would have came
out and been like hey look we're not in
love the way we were before we we we
have these kids and we're going to take
care of them and we're just like we
we're living our separate lives as
opposed to having rumors out there that
you know he's sleeping with Margo Robbie
or that he's gay or that whatever I
think in this day and age it's like hey
this is what's going on because to put
everything out like this now it's either
very calculated and like does do you cuz
some people
think that this makes will look good
like if like we have sympathy for him
that he'll be able to come back I don't
think so to me this makes it look worse
because of ass slap CU now I don't know
what was going on that night I don't
know what that was about now you know
and all the people who were like oh
comedians in their jokes it wasn't about
that at all you look so dumb right now
if you were one of those idiots who were
like well you know you about somebody's
wife or you know when you do jokes
comedians are out of pocket that I
maintain what I said last year that was
a nothing joke a dad joke oh see you in
GI Jane that was nothing this is so much
more deep it has everything to do with
this fraud of a couple it has to do with
that you know and I feel
like it's like are we
surprised like everything that that has
come out about the on her red table talk
everything that's happened with their
son who decided to like get emancipated
from them or is that the right word no
whatever that um you know when you yeah
I think that's it you know when you like
all you know all the troubles that
you've seen W with them it's not
surprising now you just go oh well y'all
have been y'all haven't been y'all
haven't been right or or what we know
about it is is is like it's all like
what like if if they were trying to lie
to the public and be like hey this is
who we are hey look at
us they didn't even do a good job of
that you know what I mean they didn't
even do a good job of like like lying to
us like you know it would we would want
to see like I don't I can't even picture
a couple that we would come out and be
like oh wow because that's happened to
me before I've had some I've had a
friend in my life who I thought their
marriage was solid like I was like oh
this is a picture perfect couple and
then like I find out later that they're
not at all and I was like wow that was
shocking if they if these two would come
out and be like yeah we've been
separated we're not really together no
one's going to be like
what Will and Jada aren't together this
is crazy no one people be like well yeah
you shouldn't be with be with each other
anyway right it's just every single
story man you look at some of these
stories that just keep coming out Jada
pigy Smith responds to rumors that she
and Will are
swingers you know it's like what now you
want to come out with all this stuff
it's all for the book
um you know about her memoirs another
one chooses to have J then they they're
talking about why they don't have a
prenup which is like whoa so when I read
that why they don't have a prenup let me
tell you something then I see why will
is like yeah we we going to live
Separate Lives okay yeah we going to
stay married you stay over there I'm
going stay over here we going to do our
thing cuz he's like he's
worth freaking Millions hundreds of
millions of dollars I don't know what
she did to make her money because the
acting career ended a while ago you know
what I mean like yeah she's been in a
couple of things but it ain't the same
she probably not getting backend
percentage on The Matrix like you know
you know what I'm saying so that's weird
um you know when she came out and said
Tupac was her soulmate I was like what
like it's this Memoir is going to be if
it's all for the Memoir it's
like this is not making Will Smith look
good at all you know uh then they have
that Will and Jada then there's so many
stories about like page six has this
will and Jada's complicated relationship
you know it's like wow man you know
let's go to this right now cuz this is
just like so crazy C you know you know
so they got like so it starts with when
they made it a first impression this was
in 1994 making it official when was this
1995 right and then they got married in
200 uh 208 she was upset by having to
walk down the aisle with three months
three months pregnant she was upset
about that um then they had then they
had their babies you know they have all
these kids
1998 open relation this is when it all
start to go crazy in 2013 with the open
relationship rumors it's like but again
like yeah like you y it's
like I don't actually have a problem
with these rich powerful people you know
working all the time and they're like
hey we want to have an open relationship
if they have the maturity to handle an
open relationship most people don't most
people can't handle that kind of stuff
because of jealousy and insecurities and
all this kind of stuff but these two
they like yeah yeah go ahead will do
your thing you know whatever okay and
then you know they the 2015 looks like
they going to split up right and then
2018 didn't refer to themselves as a
married couple uh
20120 uh alleging he had an affair with
Jada years prior oh some that that kid
the the August kid the friend of the the
the the son said that you
know they then they then they you find
out they split up in 2011 we didn't even
know that you know what I mean and then
it's like on and on and on of just like
the craziest
relationship the craziest relationship
you ever want to see man so I just I
don't freaking get it you know like what
like like what are they doing man what
are they doing
so it's like oh man I I I can't even
it's just story after Story it's so
crazy
um then she's all like Chris Rock wanted
to date she says that Chris Rock wanted
to date her amid will will divorce
reports
so that is an element to it too and I
don't even know if that's true right
then that would make sense too you
sitting in the crowd and the Oscar this
comedian who's trying to get with your
ex who you've been separated with for
years is like yo making a joke and in
his mind he's like oh this is a good
opportunity for me to go slap this dude
stay away from my ex-wife and he slaps
him right could would it could it have
been about that I mean the whole thing
becomes like in the public you know the
stupid perception that this was about a
joke and then this you know continued
attack on Comedy is not the thing you
know it's about this weird ass
couple the the most
that's what they should come out and
talk about just talk about how weird
y'all are and then we would be like
oh this makes a lot of sense you know so
it's crazy right I don't know
man Will and Jada I you know I really do
hope it works out for them you know what
I mean I wish I wish they could come out
and like not have to like live a lie you
know what I'm saying it would if if they
could just come out and be themselves
that would be great
if because they want to live in the
public eye like I like I'm not somebody
that thinks that you have to have all
your information out it's not none of
nobody's business but if you are a
couple that's like want your business
out there if you have like everything on
your Instagram is about like sharing
sharing sharing you have this like talk
show where it's like we're sharing we're
sharing we're we're working on things
and we're sharing if you're people that
want to share everything about your life
then then hopefully you'll be able to
live true you know and not feel the
pressure of societal nonsense you know
what I mean it's crazy all right now I
want to talk about something real real
touchy okay and I waited till the end to
talk about this because as you
know there's like a conflict in
Israel full disclosure my wife's Jewish
and her whole
family I I spend more time talking to
them than I ever talked to my current
family my my my blood relatives I have
three blood relatives I talk to
frequently uh my mom who has
dementia my my cousin Alysa you know and
my other cousin Angelique that's pretty
much all I you know I don't have a big
family so anyways these these people who
I've been interacting with for a year
now great people you
know but this this conflict is
happening between Israel and Palestine
Hamas and all that stuff going on I'm
going to say this I'm because I'm not
I'm anti-war I feel like that in this
modern
times to have a conflict that
involves Warfare explosions and and guns
and the Innocents that die because of
that it's
terrible it just is terrible you
know so whatever side you want to be on
it doesn't matter to me what matters to
me is that this isn't the way they're
going to resolve this issue but I will
say this
man I'm not and I and and shout out to
Michael Costa who is the uh was did a CO
did a guest hosting for the The Daily
Show and he had just great Instagram
posts and I totally agree with him like
I am not educated enough to understand
this situation to just blanketly be like
I support this and that so I'm
supporting anti-war I'm supporting
Innocents and no innocent Liv should be
killed because of this conflict you know
that's what I'm about and I would
suggest to everyone to to like do some
research on your own just to find out
what's going on I mean it is a long
history of what's happening in the
Middle East area what's going on in that
that stretch of land and how long this
conflict has been going on and it's been
going on long enough and there's a lot
so much has happened that it is not in
my opinion right to just blanketly be
like oh like this act is wrong and it
represents the whole conflict because it
doesn't it really doesn't and just doing
my own research I went to perplexity
just just in full disclosure perplexity
AI you know you just write what's the
history of Israel you know um you know
and and just some of the things are like
you know there you know just get your
history cuz it goes back so far man it
goes back the creation of Israel sparked
a in 1948 there was a war okay let's go
back to like the Holocaust you know it's
like you got the Holocaust and then this
is what happened to the Jews and then
now after the Holocaust is the Jews
trying to be like hey we need our own
place can we H can we have a place for
ourselves look what you've done to us to
our people so that's a big spark that's
what I'm saying it's very Nuance it goes
back then 1948 you know they had this
war you know in May 14th 1948 they
established the state of Israel you know
and they took over this land and the
Palestinian people who were there were
forced
out so when I read that and I'm looking
at this I go well man well that means
this is like a conflict that was decided
in the wrong way in the first place but
who wants to give up their land nobody
does you know people have this goes back
that part of the world they have a rich
history you know in the United States we
we don't even understand that because we
only go back what 250 years where we
took over the land from people like we
always forgetting that like we kicked
the Indians off the land right we we did
bad land deals and you know that's why
they got casinos and stuff like that you
know we're trying to like make up for
what we did you know but we're we don't
have this Rich history that goes back
back back back back these people do all
the people in that region have a long
Rich history of like who owns the land
and who doesn't own the land so they're
fighting over this conflict and it's
been going on for for years when I
started doing research man this [__]
goes back to like
1897 of like so what I'm saying is a lot
of things have happened and you should
read about it I I really recommend
everybody read up about it you know
because you can't you can't trust the
media now and and you can't trust like
people even like myself being like
here's my opinion and think that that's
my opinion is um completely informed
because it's not this is why I'm not
saying anything necessarily concrete
because when I look at this stuff it
really gives me a different perspective
and and you know my favorite word it is
very nuanced this situation you know
when you hear you know cuz then you have
the and the issu is you have this Hamas
right and they're this founded in 19 uh
887 and their whole thing is H they have
vowed to annihilate Israel Hamas you
know what I mean like they are
completely anti-jewish people but
they're not the ones they're don't they
don't control the they're not
representing all of the Palestinian
people it's just this terrorist
organization or but they but they even
you look at their history they probably
think they're Freedom Fighters you know
these people probably think you know
well we're just trying to take back our
land and this is how we're doing it
right and then the other side responds
accordingly and they're both doing that
to each other I mean the list of
atrocities that go on on both sides for
for countless and countless years makes
you like as an outsider being like well
I don't know what this is about we've
been hearing about this for years you
know when I was a kid you hear about
remember like the older people on on
here know remember peace in the Middle
East that was like a big thing we'd
always hear all the time peace in the
Middle East right I I remember thinking
now I look back and go I don't know if I
really knew what that even meant or if I
knew who they were talking about what
was the piece for who between who and
who and why and who's right and who's
wrong I don't think there's a clear
who's right and who's wrong and my clear
point about this is I just think that
the innocent lives that are being
wrecked on both sides is
like nobody wants that we wouldn't want
that here we wouldn't we wouldn't want
that be happening here if we were having
a fight with Canada or Mexico or where
the borders are close we wouldn't want
to be like you know launching bombs and
stuff in between two places it's crazy
so I I
hope you know I just want peace I just
want peace I just want like how about
even if you don't like each other is
there some sort of diplomatic way to
work on this you know we don't like
places we don't like Russia we don't
like China they don't like us but but
we're in business with them you know
what I'm saying like that's the world we
live in now the modern world is like
yeah we don't like what you're doing but
hey we need your products so we're not
the over there it's like they don't care
their whole thing is like we got to
destroy you you got to we have to defend
ourselves or destroy it's like all about
it's all it's it seems very
like old school biblical ass fighting
and I just I don't like it you know and
and and the last thing is like I don't
understand
okay so Israel has this massive Defense
Force you know they have this military
they have nuclear weapons I believe they
have uh you know this really Advanced
missile launch system to like protect
their
lands and then this attack happens it's
a massive security breakdown right okay
I don't understand that but here's the
thing I also don't understand
if knowing this about
them why would you
attack like this I just don't get it I
don't get like if if what Hamas did
would be like walking up to Mike Tyson
open hand slapping him on the face and
then being like this
what what do you think's goingon to
happen that's why this don't make any
sense to me like if you're gonna attack
attack I'm not for war or anything like
that I'm just saying it don't seem like
that was a smart thing so what what you
going to go you goingon to kill 1300
people you're going to like have some
weird coordinated attack for what
purpose when when this place controls
the water and food supply to the
Palestinian people they they they have
they're in charge of that why would you
do this attack I just I don't get it it
don't make any sense to me y'all if I
was right a movie script you know if I
was writing a movie script it would be
there would be like some serious
conspiracies going on here uh of why
this happened this like security breach
and uh this weird little attack where
people are dying uh but but like not on
a mass scale and then all of a sudden
now we have this huge um conflict that
started right it's really crazy but
anyways the real point of this is I I do
suggest all of you do some research man
with with with whatever with AI with
Google with whatever you want to use
just just get some history get the
history of Israel get the history of the
Jewish people the history of the
Palestinian people so you can be like
more informed when you're looking at
your Instagram and you're seeing like
celebrities and comics and people saying
things when you're looking at the news
the images that the news are giving you
so you could be like whoa I don't cuz
honestly I don't understand at all and
I'm not claiming that I do the little
bit of research I just did for this
podcast episode I was like wow this is a
lot and it makes me want to read more
about it so my stance is I'm anti-war I
don't want War I don't want innocent
people dying you know for what for for
for for this for these politics that we
don't know anything about we can't put
our fingers on it you know so again I'll
say it again make sure
[Music]
you make sure you um do some research
yourself just so you can like when you
see stuff you can go huh because you
know you you might see a post you'll be
like why is that person supporting that
side whatever side it is right do some
research and you might have like a like
a some more empathy for for you be like
oh wow I think that they're doing this
because of this not to say that it's
right but you go oh I might have a you
might have like you can go oh and that's
when you know like we should stay out of
this you know we should stay out of this
so it's a lot man um it's a lot and I I
feel I feel for I feel for all the
innocent families and and people that
have been killed in this conflict and I
hope they find a resolution soon all
right anyways guys no RP recap today on
this you know ending it like that but I
appreciate everybody that comes and
watches the podcast weekly if you're new
to the podcast thanks for being here you
know if you're uh you know if you've uh
you're here all the time you know how we
do I appreciate you guys and just I also
want to say make sure you come check me
out make sure you come check me out and
my dates that I have coming up you know
again this weekend I'll be in Dana
October 20th to the 21st Comedy Zone
October 27th to 28th the Orlando Improv
November 2nd and sides Splitters Tampa
Florida November 3rd and
4th um
anyways guys um I appreciate you being
here and as always thanks for watching
Griffin with Griffin and I will see you
next
week yes